thanks for being here and thanks for the
kind introduction a gym the I wasn't
planning to talk too much about Unilever
if you don't mind
he said enough already about it so
that's probably where it stops
but flying in and this morning to to
come here I had to take an early plane
and I was sitting there at the airport
in Los Angeles and I overheard three
people talking and I know it's very
unpolite to listen to people talking at
an airport but I know you all do so I'm
not I'm not ashamed to share the story
with you but I quickly discovered that I
was an engineer and economist and a
doctor and they were bragging and the
doctor said hey we have the eye of the
oldest profession in the world and the
other side why is this he said well you
go to the book of Genesis you know Eve
came out of the ribs of Adam and both of
Adam came out of the ribs of Eva whoever
both of them survived that was the first
successful operation doctors at the
oldest profession and the engineer said
I don't think so because when there was
chaos we created the universe and to
make order out of chaos you have to be
an engineer so engineers are the oldest
profession and the economists said I
don't think so because who created chaos
in the first place and I think that
describes a little bit what I want to
talk about today who created chaos in
the first place but before I do that let
me first tell you how pleased I am to be
here in this Conrad from Google Berg
Memorial Lecture we were just talking
with some of the kind people who have
known him and studied with him in the
class of 87 but he seemed to have been a
remarkable person and and frankly a
little bit ahead of his time as I said
then I would love to have met him but
it's certainly an honor to be part of
his life indirectly by recognizing him
and doing that in a school like Stanford
obviously is a wonderful opportunity you
have a great institution here and out
early I'll call my mother today and tell
her I was at Stanford and she'll be very
proud
but you you also have a very progressive
and we were talking that vision towards
what the role of the education should be
and the people that you are producing
here for tomorrow's wealth
you've been very instrumental as Jim
said to work on the high carbon stock
issues around for deforestation etc and
we don't have the academic world
actively involved I don't think we can
solve so many of the world's problems
and we had a chance this morning with a
tremendous group of professors and
faculty and PhD students and others to
talk a little bit about the challenges
of palm oil in the supply chain which
are not all that obvious and to think
about that together the more you talk
about it means that these issues are
solvable but we all need to contribute
our own individual parts to this and as
a university I think more than ever
showing your leadership in the area of
sustainability will place you very well
because the future issues that we need
to solve are obviously the challenges of
climate and energy or water or
biodiversity or natural capital and many
of the other things the students that
are here I think the skill sets that we
need to learn to be successful in life
undoubtedly many of them are going to be
the same as we've always had many
hard-working people a certain level of
intelligence integrity all these things
are not going to change but increasingly
we need to have some other skill sets to
be successful in this world and clearly
many people struggle with that otherwise
I believe we would have solved already
some of the challenges that are out
there but to be a good business person
you need to know as much in the future
in my opinion about sustainability as
you know about sales so you need to know
as much about climate change as you do
about cash flow or you need to know as
much about international development
that you do about business development
it really requires a broader vision if
you want to manage these challenges that
we know we we are seeing everyday in
this world the first thing to start on a
little bit of a positive note I think
it's actually a great time to be here if
you look at the last 15 years the world
has actually come quite a
way we've seen the effects of
globalization actually benefiting many
people as we can see that the spreads of
some of these ideals of democracy or the
opportunities that it offered by getting
an increasingly integrated global
economy and an interdependent world has
undoubtedly lifted many people out of
poverty in fact in the last few decades
more people have been lifted out of
poverty than any time in human history
more people are going to school any time
in human history more people have access
to clean drinking water or sanitation
and yes it's also true that more women
are actually participating in the global
economy than ever in fact the original
goals that we set in 2004 the global
agenda which were called the Millennial
Development Goals had as a simple
objective to halve the number of people
living in poverty over the 15-year
period from the year 2000 to 2015 and in
fact we have achieved that we have
achieved that and we should be proud
about that this is a healthier and
wealthier world than at any time and but
at the same time I have to take a step
back a little bit after these 15 years
and it reminds me a little bit of
Dickens who wrote in the 1850s his book
1870s at the Tale of Two Cities at that
time he was talking about Paris and
London I'm spending most of my time in
London but his book starts was it was
the best of times it was the worst of
times and I think we're a little bit in
that situation right now but we've
lifted enormous amounts of people out of
poverty
we also have still challenges that need
to be solved and many of these
challenges actually I think we became
fully aware of that in the crisis in
2007-2008 some people said it's a
financial crisis then some people said
it's a governmental crisis then it
became economic crisis and we're still
recuperating from that in fact it was
the worst crisis on record since the
Great Depression in the 20s and I think
it made us realize I've always found by
the way that this was more of a crisis
of morality than anything else but it
made us realise that the system we had
created
had certainly lifted so many people out
of poverty but it wasn't quite
sustainable it came at an enormous cost
a high level of private or or government
depth in enormous level of
overconsumption and frankly leaving too
many people behind I've always said that
in any system where too many people feel
that they're not participating or are
being left behind that system will
ultimately Rebelle against itself just
like a cancer in a body and you've seen
that happen actually increasingly so the
question is have we learnt anything
since this crisis I hope the answer
would be affirmative but if you look at
the heart numbers you have to really ask
yourself questions the depth that cost
this crisis by the way an economic
system that was very much around we
asked the Saudis to pump the oil we
asked the Chinese to produce the plastic
and we asked the Americans to consume
that's basically what we were doing in a
very simplistic way and you'd think we
would have learned from that now that we
are AGS further or nine years further
but the global depth actually has gone
up by another 57 trillion that's 40%
more global debt obviously quantitative
easing and all these things have played
a role for it basically in Europe and
the US companies actually you see the
same behavior very little investment in
the future of companies more being given
back on special dividends and share
buybacks
and the financial side because of this
abundancy of capital but very limited
amounts of money are entering in the
real economy you look at overconsumption
I think was still on this linear
consumption paths only 10% of the
packaging for example cats we used 90%
ends up in landfills and unfortunately
more and more in the oceans that's not
going to last either so on the
consumption pattern we still haven't
moved to a circular consumption pattern
at the speed that is required in fact
you take the top 1.2 billion people in
this world did two bids we all be long
believe it or not but the top one point
two billion people consumed 75% of the
world's resources and the bottom 1
billion only 1% but I can assure you if
you're on the ball
you all aspire to live like us and the
numbers just don't add up anymore we're
living way beyond the limits of our
planetary boundaries and climate change
obviously is one of the effects that we
see and then you think we left too many
people behind well
we're again a little bit further and and
frankly in the next the aid year since
the crisis the Gini coefficient in all
countries in the world has actually gone
up the only country that is an exception
I believe is Ecuador by memory but the
rest we've actually increased the gap
there are now 62 people in this world
that have the same net wealth as the
bottom 95% like the top 1% in the world
as sorry the bottom three and a half
billion the top 1% in the world has the
same wealth as the bottom 99% we've
created really a system that is not
sustainable but we've not certainly not
made it better and one of the key
effects that you see from this is
climate change in fact the World Bank
Jim Kim estimates that if we as you know
we've just passed the one degree towards
the two degrees which is about the
maximum that everybody sort of thinks
that this world can handle before the
consequences become dear lots of people
are starting to talk now about one and a
half degrees in fact scientists are
finding out with the bleaching of the
coral reefs for example that one in
above one and a half degrees the coral
reefs are gone
scientifically now basically
well-established and if that happens you
put the livelihood of about a billion
people at risk again but interestingly
Jim Kim from the World Bank issued a
report fairly recently that if we stay
on the current trajectory then about a
hundred million more people will fall
into poverty climate change as I've said
many times it's actually a human
development agenda it's the poor that
suffer when you had hurricane sandy or
other things in the US I have sons
living in New York they had a great time
climbing the stairs they didn't have to
go to the gym they saw some people a
little bit more than they were watching
television but in the end of the day
within a few weeks you were back with
the resilience you've built up with the
people in high ET and others they were
pushed back another few years climate
change is a development agenda issue
more than anything else
fourteen over the last 15 years have
been the warmer
some records California has not been
excluded from this I think Jerry Brown
has be a fairly outspoken governor in
this state and the water shortages that
you have any extensions of the
limitations of water you can use as a
good example of that in fact the IMF
estimates that the real cost of climate
change to the global economy already
today if you include everything which is
air pollution you know in China 1.8
million people a year lose their lives
of lose their lives to air pollution but
you count all the externalities in there
they're estimating that that is about
five point three trillion dollars
already now it in costs of actually not
acting we're just looking at the London
School of Economics I guess one of your
competitors to some extent that said
that climate change is actually the
economic losses could go to about 27
trillion dollars that's about 20% of the
world's assets that's quite a lot and
the sustainable accounting standard
board said in fact if you look in the
u.s. 93% of the US equities would
actually be at risk because of climate
change and it's not just a financial
side of that WWF was calculating that in
the last since the 70s
we have about lost about 50% of our
mammals reptiles or birds so it's a
question a little bit of when is it our
turn in my opinion if we don't take any
actions without being a doomsday
scenario I was reading a book off from
Hubert Reeves who is the Canadian
philosopher and human Reef's said
something that stuck to me when I read
this he said man is the most insane
species he worships an invisible God and
this choice of visible nature not
realizing that the visible nature he
destroys is the invisible God he
worships and that is about what we are
doing right now and that's obviously not
a pathway that is sustainable so I was
very glad to see 2015 hopefully being a
watershed year because in 2015 two
historic things happened first of all
the signing of the sustainable
development goals in September of the UN
which are the follow-up from the
Millennial Development Goal
covering the next 15 years well rounded
93 countries in the world went together
and said for the next 15 years we have
an opportunity to irreversibly eradicate
poverty irreversibly eradicate poverty
in a more sustainable and equitable way
out of that came 17 goals goal number
one obviously poverty alleviation goal
number two food security goal number
five gender equality call number six
water sanitation goal number sixteen
governments call number seventeen
partnerships sixteen goals that if we
would work all these goals we could
indeed do that and the first test of
these sustainable development goals came
in December last year in Paris with the
famous cop21 the cop21
where all the countries in the world
again about 190 countries submitted
their intended nationally determined
commitments what they thought they could
do to stem the tide of climate change we
were on a four degree trajectory and lo
and behold in Paris with the agreement
we've actually bent that curve the
agreement covers all countries four
times more than the Kyoto Protocol and
it was on a voluntary basis you propose
just adding up what was proposed no
backsliding cannot go back five-year
review 100 billion dollars a year
financing to move forward obviously and
help the pool countries a pretty good
agreement as a starting point obviously
we've discovered that we cannot wait
till the end of the century to tackle
climate change and now we have to work
on accelerating it but the base has been
laid so I'm actually very pleased that
for the first time in history we could
be be the generation if you want to and
especially the young people here that
solve poverty which is a noble goal to
go for by itself but also ensure that
future generations don't have to deal
anymore with the effects of climate
change I was very pleased a few weeks
ago in New York where I was present when
175 member state countries actually
ratified the Paris agreement we need 55
percent of the countries fifty-five
percent of the carbon emission to make
that go into law but interesting to see
the US right now
the Chinese and some others are actually
trying to push this agenda forward to
ensure a more rapid implementation now
this agenda which is an enormous agenda
for humanity zero poverty zero carbon
emission I don't think any
businessperson would set such an
audacious goal for his own business and
certainly not if you tell him or her
that it's in the next 15 years more or
less that the thing needs to happen so
we won't get there if we don't work all
together
and business has an enormous role to
play which is the only thing really I
want to leave you is that more
businesses need to start taking a higher
level of responsibility to be part of
that solution after all there is no
business case and enduring poverty I've
discovered that a long time ago even in
our company which is fortunate enough to
be in a hundred ninety countries are
reached two billion consumers a day we
have to be sure that this as a more
inclusive society an interesting
statistic not to bother you is that but
the world spends nine point seven
trillion a year on violence and war
Prevention's and spending zone actually
having these things nine point seven
trillion if we would just take that
money which says three times higher than
the development agenda I'm talking about
we could wipe out all the depth in the
emerging markets with that and we could
give some let level some of the money
still that is left to Europe to start
stabilizing their European monetary
system if we wanted to this is just a
little plea from my home base so that we
get a little bit for this but this is
what we are currently doing this world
has become reactive and spends behind
the symptoms of the the results instead
of attacking the cause you see the same
in error other areas by the way
healthcare is a good example where you
have an enormous epidemic coming up of
diabetes tube is obesity and we end up
spending all the money treating it
instead of going to prevention this is
very much what we're doing in the global
economy as well now you won't solve this
development agenda if you don't get
business involved it's very simple
development agenda as I mentioned cost
about two to three trillion dollars a
year which by the way is a pimple on a
global economy of one hundred two
hundred ten trillion dollars it's
actually a shame that we have to talk or
knock on people's doors and as we know
there's enough money that is going
around just have to put it to better use
but the overseas development aid from
all the government's in the world has
come down now to about a hundred sixty
billion dollars and the pressure is more
downwards and upwards with all these
these attempts to reduce these
government deficits so you need to use
that relatively small amount of money to
unlock the private sector financing to
make this development agenda a common
life now another statistic that would
show you why the private sector should
be involved is because if you look in
basically the emerging markets which
will be eighty percent of the world
population very soon you'll have the
private sector be sixty percent of the
GDP about 80 percent of the financial
flow and ninety percent of the job
creation so if you don't involve the
private sector it's very hard to see how
you can actually then solve these things
and then the bigger companies have to be
obviously even more so involved the top
thousand companies in this world have
actually about fifty percent of the
world market cap and not only depth they
actually have they've done are in terms
of revenues you're talking about thirty
five trillion dollars so if you don't
get these big companies involved you
don't get to that tipping point and
we're obviously one of those so yes
there is a self-interest to make these
economies function but it is also an
enormous opportunity for business
obviously if they understand this and be
part of this not being part of it I
think risk the very essence of your
business model in the first place now
business has many responsibilities I
always like to quote Viktor Frankl who
wrote his book man's search for meaning
Viktor Frankl was a survivor of Nazi
Germany and in his book he wrote that
when they built the Statue of Liberty on
the east coast of the United States they
forgot to build a statue of
responsibility on the west coast
there is no
Liberty without responsibility so if
you're a company of our size or if
you're a country like the US or others
then you need to have that
responsibility to actively be part of
that solution for business it obviously
means responsibilities toward human
rights towards paying our fair tax in
the places that we operate towards being
part of fighting this enormous disease
of corruption that is still everywhere
in many places in the world and I think
an increasing amount of businesses start
to understand that enough for sure or
not but an increasing amount is business
starts to understand also increasingly
that not acting might actually have a
higher cost and acting I think we're
actually at that point right now that
the cost of inaction is higher than the
cost of action and you see that again if
you look at some of these numbers of
climate change but you look at food
security this is still a world where
about 800 million people go to bed
hungry every night not even knowing if
they wake up the next day which is
totally unexplainable if you learn at
the same time realize that we're wasting
30 to 40 percent of the food that we're
producing as if we don't care the food
that we waste is about 80 billion sorry
eight hundred billion dollars every year
forget the effects on climate change and
all the other things that's just a small
detail that comes with it but we're
wasting 800 billion dollars in food
whilst it actually only takes eighty
billion to feed these people that go to
bed hungry
isn't that an equation that humanity
should be able to solve and yet we're
unable on the g7 or the g20 to get food
security on the agenda and in fact as
far as I'm concerned a scandal now
equally there are enormous opportunities
in this development agenda opportunities
for business for all businesses if they
really understand that just investing
equally in this world
in women as we do in men access to
financing education land rights which
unfortunately is not the case in the
majority of the country still would
unlock the global economy by 28 trillion
dollars any one dollar investment in
nutrition we still have rounded 60
million stunted children being born
a year and it could be your child or
mine just investing $1 gives a $17 back
to society investing $1 in water and
sanitation has a payback of 6 dollars
any business would really love to have
these returns on their investments and
yet why don't we do that if we have such
enormous opportunities why can we not
get the world together and do this I
think the first main element that is
clearly missing is trust it's an easy
word trust but we are running currently
a society where everybody mistrust each
other if you look at the Edelman survey
which is published every year at the
time of the World Economic Forum you
will see that trust in government sits
at an all-time low
trust in business trust in CEOs even
lower and as a result of that obviously
many people have given up I think one of
the extremes that you see this year and
your political cycle in this country
which is a great amusement to all of us
living abroad and I'm glad I live abroad
watching it from a distance but it is
really people are fed up they've all
become against anything because the
established order is clearly not
attacking the issues that need to be
attacked with a maturity and a sense of
morality that is needed and that is the
same by the way in many other countries
it just kept doesn't get as much share
of voice as obviously the US media does
but Trust is very low and Trust in
business is even lower as I said and
that's not surprising because we've seen
it enormous amounts of scandals and
normally I could take the financial
times of the day and I can open every
day of financial times and there's one
or another company that gets caught
because they refuse to invest in safety
and the wells in the Gulf or they infuse
to refuse to invest in the safety of
their workers and the factory collapses
in Bangladesh or they manipulate LIBOR
or foreign exchange rates or they they
start to tinkle with the emission
standards of their engines and the list
goes on the list goes on and in this
aids of transparency what companies need
to understand is that there isn't really
any place to hide anymore
I don't think that these issues are more
or less than they were before but they
are certainly more transparent than they
were before that I can tell you
so companies need to take notice of that
and be sure that the way they operate is
you know is transparent and take
responsibility for that if we want to
build that trust trust can only come
from transparency transparency builds
trust and Trust is needed to build
prosperity and anytime these companies
don't behave responsibly you see over
and over that about 30 to 40 percent of
their market cap disappears so
increasingly not surprisingly it's
interesting also to the financial market
that want to know that what they are
investing is you know is responsible
investing the other thing we need is
obviously transparency as I said that
cause with trust I don't think you can
build trust without that transparency we
are publishing far more data now as a
company than we've ever done in the
history of mankind I believe and we will
continue to do that because by showing
what we do by giving access to that to
many people we can build that the other
thing that is needed is a different
business model if you want to solve all
these issues like climate change our
food security or poverty alleviation or
access to clean drinking water or
education if you want to you cannot be
victim to the quarterly reporting this
market and this world has become
incredibly short-term incredibly mine
optic and many companies unfortunately
would forego would forego doing the
right decisions long term if it affects
their quarterly profits versus market
guidance we've become very mine optic
and not surprisingly the average length
of a publicly traded company in the u.s.
now has come down to 17 years the
average tenure of a CEO is now four and
a half years in that short cycle these
longer-term issues that really are
important for all of us are not getting
the attention that they need so you need
different business models and Unilever
when I became CEO we stopped doing
quarterly reporting we stopped giving
guidance we moved our compensation
systems to the long term but more
importantly we develop business models
that really are firmly ingrained in the
in the principle of partnerships it was
Einstein who said the definition of
insanity is to do the same thing over
and over again and expect different
results that's not going to work anymore
we've come so far if we now really want
to snap out of this and create this
better world for everybody
we have to become adults and start
working at a different level as well and
that different level has to come via
trust as I mentioned but certainly a
different form of partnership as well
it's a partnership more than just you
and I working together because the two
of us can do more than each of us
individually it's first and foremost a
partnership for the common good where we
put the interest of others ahead of our
own knowing that by doing so we will
actually be better off in the longer
term if we get that higher level of
partnership of moral morality if you
want to I think we can solve any of the
world's problems we don't need more PhDs
and due respect or sent missions to Mars
to find the answer for most of these
issues of the development agenda we have
the answer and frankly increasingly we
see others becoming aware of the
enormous potentials or the downside of
risks if we don't act I personally would
only want to invest in companies that
create a better future where I can
retire in or my children can live in so
we see people becoming much more
conscious of how they use the power of
their wallet Millennials are the best
example of that in fact this is the
first year that the Millennials in the
u.s. will have the same number of
folding power as the baby boomers
unfortunately they are not as a
politically engaged because they've been
turned off a little bit by what is
happening but it's the same now in 2020
which is not that far off we have
significantly more Millennials as
folding power these people are far more
Purpose Driven they are far more
conscious of how they put their dollars
to use and and hopefully will be a big
wave of change that will benefit us all
but the financial evidence is also there
I personally don't believe that the
thing will move at the speed that we
need to move it if we don't get the
financial market involved unfortunately
if you want to it is still a market a
global economy that very heavily depends
on that and the interesting thing is
that most of the studies now actually
show that companies that are more
transparent obviously take risks away
from the financial market and have a
lower cost of capital it also shows that
you get better operational
performance companies that think about
climate change or some of these issues
also make their whole value chain more
resilient and then not surprisingly the
stock price performance everything else
being equal is actually better of
companies that are more responsible in
this market the what Unilever has done
was that Unilever sustainable living
plan that Jim briefly referred to is
actually create a business model where
we totally decoupled our growth from
environmental impact and increase our
overall social impact but the difference
from CSR and staying in your own shop if
you want to or making it only part of
your company is that we fully integrate
this in all we do it is in fact our
business model and we take
responsibility of the total value chain
you cannot solve issues if you just stay
in your own narrow little box and work
in silos if in our case you're in the
food business you have to take
responsibility from the farm to the fork
and all the issues that are in between
the issue of malnutrition are stunting
the issues of climate smart agriculture
the issues of food waste the issues of
creating jobs for smallholder farmers
the issue of deforestation half of it
driven by the enormous demand of food
and on the other hand the issues of
obesity and some of the other things we
talked about yes if you want to be a
responsible company and you're in that
business you then also have to be co
responsible to finding solutions to
these issues that show up in your total
failure chain I think that the
divestiture movement or the financial
market is getting increasingly
interested in this agenda we had in
Paris at the cop21 $24,000 of capital
and the management asking for a price on
carbon we thought in Paris that we could
get the divestiture movement you know
the carbon diversity you see a lot of
that at universities now is your
endowment funds etc we thought we could
get to a hundred billion we actually got
900 billion at the time of Paris and
that number has gone up to 2.7 trillion
now so the financial market is catching
on and you can see that 57 companies in
the UK in the USF gone bankrupt that
were in the coal business Peabody the
last one just in the last two years
alone you can see it in other things
Tesla makes actually relatively few
their model three tremendously popular
325,000 orders for that car in the first
few days alone despite selling less than
one 120 or 130 is of the cars of General
Motors it has already half the market
cap of General Motors increasingly the
financial community is feeding is
folding with their wallets and they're
getting actively involved as they see
this as an enormous risk but also an
enormous opportunity investment in green
energy right now is far exceeding the
investment in fossil fuel even with the
low prices in fact that we have now let
me pick up pace and do only one or two
more things before we open it up to Q&A
s I think the first one is the
Millennials because they're many
Millennials and in the audience and I
would just say that a purpose driven
business model makes a lot more sense
only 30 percent of Millennials actually
want to work for corporates they just
don't feel it's cool anymore to work for
corporates for the reasons that we
mentioned since we moved to this much
more stronger purpose driven business
model we actually find ourselves to be
the third most looked up company and
LinkedIn after Google and Apple not even
being a product named Unilever is sort
of the holding name and are all of our
products have different names we get one
point eight million people applying to
our company every year and in most
countries that we operate were the
preferred employers so even from that
point of view it makes sense to be able
to attract the best and brightest would
certainly guarantee a future of your
company what we also see clearly is that
Millennials don't want to just be part
of this they very much understand that
the next 15 years are going to be
crucial for them they want to be an
active part in shaping this future I had
the pleasure to be serving on the
high-level panel to develop these
sustainable development goals for the
secretary-general and we put his website
out there the world we want and within a
nanosecond we had over a million young
people many from Africa writing down
what they want they want to be actively
involved in shaping this agenda and too
often we still exclude as young
generation next to the Millennials we
also obviously need a different type of
leadership I was very excited to hear
that here at Stanford you're actually
to put this curriculum together for
future leaders and that you have a first
one coming home with the young global
leaders from the World Economic Forum
that's a very exciting step you're
taking there but it is very clear that
the leaders of tomorrow need to be
Purpose Driven need to be able to work
in partnership need to feel comfortable
with that level of transparency need to
be systemic thinkers to be able to
handle this complexity but above all
need to be human beings human beings
with a high level of awareness and
engagement and a certain level of
humanity and humility if we get more of
these leaders and we're clearly short of
it now looking at the average tenure of
a CEO but if we get more of these
leaders I think that we're on the right
path to solve some of these key issues
that we have so in conclusion I think
we're we should not feel despair I think
we're moving in the right direction but
the challenge is obviously how fast we
move because the longer we wait the more
difficult the challenge will be or the
more expensive it will be but for me the
reason to move fast is the longer we
wait the more people will live in
poverty and there is no excuse that we
let that happen I've always felt that if
you belong to the 2% of the world
population that can do and like what
they want go to wonderful institutions
like this find the jobs they like our
work don't have to worry about that
child not making the age of five or
being stunted or being included in the
workforce and all the other things if
you belong to those two percent then
it's obviously your obligation to work
for the other 98% and that is what we're
trying to do in Unilever was Martin
Luther King that actually said that
everyone can be great because everyone
can serve and all of us in our own
humble ways can make that difference to
together create a better world for all
and certainly for generations to come
and that's obviously the world I want to
live in and I want to be part of that
challenge to say this is what we really
did in the coming 15 years so that
nobody else has to worry about these
challenges I like the Dali Lama one of
the things the Dalai Lama said that
if you seek enlightenment for yourself
simply to enhance yourself and your
position you miss purpose but if you
seek enlightenment for yourself to
enable you to serve others you are with
purpose so my message to you very simply
is go with purpose thank you very much
well Paul thank you so much for those
inspiring words
I think we're you've left us with many
things to think about but there were
some exciting things you said there are
signs that governments companies people
in general are normally more aware we're
taking action to do something about the
development agenda about sustainability
but that was not really the case a few
years back when you took over Unilever
as CEO and you came in first day and
made huge changes well how did you
handle all the challenges and the
resistance that came with that well so I
had they were changes indeed but first
of all there was a burning platform and
in fact I had two of them I came in from
the outside which helped a little bit by
not being so biased I thought some of
the changes that needed to be made
perhaps but the business was not doing
so well so that was a burning platform
and then you had the crisis in 2007-2008
so it wasn't difficult to convince
people that we needed to do things
differently because I came in from the
outside and actually I had worked what
some people thought was was competition
in the past I don't have that concept
myself but they some people felt that
the Troy in house was led into the
company and I discovered very early on
that it was for me to prove that I could
be part of the team instead of them to
prove that they could be part of my team
and I had to establish myself so I spent
an enormous amount of time digging into
the history of the company Jim Collins
in his book from good to great talks
about nurturing the core before you
stimulate progress and we actually went
back to the roots of this company we
actually went to Port Sunlight which is
in the in the north of England where the
company had started the symbolically had
a meeting there was our senior
management
and discussed a little bit what had made
this company great and we came to some
enormous failures and one of them is
certainly doing well by doing good this
was a man by the way that instituted in
the UK the six hour six hour a day which
was very revolutionary in the eighteen
hundred's I can tell you when he became
Lord and he went into Parliament he
introduced the pension plans he was open
when his employees would go to war
volunteer for the wars that were there
the World War one and World War two
he obviously dealt only was world war
one but guaranteed the wages to the
wives so that they could live and so he
was an extraordinary man in that sense
but always of the belief of doing well
by doing good founding the Marine
Stewardship of sustainable fishery at a
round table of sustainable development
so what we did is we took all that
strengths and said can we not turn that
into a business model that is
desperately needed right now where we
link all of this and see this as an
increasingly powerful driver for future
business growth and what the surprise in
all of this it's hard work it's not that
easy obviously and some people are
always skeptical but you need them to
make better plans but people really
quite quickly taught something when it
is a higher purpose and want to be part
of that people want to make a difference
they want to leave this world in a
little bit better place they want to
touch people positively and if you can
work for a company that where those
values can come alive then people feel
happier and we've seen it in our
engagement scores which were sort of in
the bottom Tirzah when we started and
now they're off the map because people
want to be part of us so on that note
can you tell us when did you find
purpose in promoting sustainability as a
business practice well it was always
said the question is always why didn't
our predecessors deal with this as much
as they should have and the answer is
really there wasn't the issue wasn't so
evident because we've lifted so many
people out of poverty we really got the
issues of planetary boundaries if you go
back even at the time that the original
Millennial Development Goals where were
developed the word sustainable didn't
show up there even there were issues of
HIV there were issues in the
eloping markets now many of these issues
have become global because of our
interdependent world so it's only in the
last 10 years I think that people have
become fully aware of what needs it to
be changed and that's why you see this
momentum now but I would not worry about
that what we have to now do is just to
be sure that we can accelerate because
as usual there's always a little bit of
festered order that doesn't like to
change if you're on the right side of
the equation in this transformation of
this global economy you are more likely
to be resistant than if you are not
cutting the benefits on the global
economy but the reality right now is
that about 99 percent of the people are
not getting the benefits of the global
economy anymore so I hope we can build
this momentum and accelerate that to
make the changes by the way nothing to
do with being democrat or republican or
being a Dutchman often accused of
smoking pot and all the other things
which is liberalized in our country it
just has to do with a common-sense
agenda to make this world work for all
of us long term if you see the cost that
Europe now has on refugees for example
is enormous and then if you see the
money that we spent is a pittance to
actually solve these issues so it's
becoming increasingly transparent I
think that this is an agenda for
Humanity the way you frame things to me
it sounds like today there's also
momentum and today we are still at an
inflection point companies could use to
change business practices and yet you
don't see you know those that do stand
out because not many are doing it yeah
that's a good question that's a good
question but yeah I start from the
premise that I believe in the goodness
of people because I never met a CEO who
wants more unemployment or more climate
change or more pollution unless they
don't tell me but but they I don't think
they're there really so you have to
believe in the goodness of all of us and
then you have to ask yourself the
question well if that is the case why
doesn't it happen and there obviously
many reasons for that the global economy
isn't functioning so you have to work
very hard to even keep your own company
afloat
these issues of tenure that you might
not have the skill sets so there many of
those reasons but I think in essence it
boils down to the behavior of people is
is governed by the boundaries in which
you operate and that is true for all of
us if you become a father or a mother
and you have children you start to get
different boundaries and you have
different behaviors you might not go out
to the bar every night anymore with your
buddies you might want to do a little
bit more babysitting or sit together
with your kids if I tell a Salesman that
he gets rewarded on the number of orders
he writes sales orders he's going to
split many orders and writes a lot of
orders if I tell him he's going to be
rewarded on the total sales volume he
brings in he might have a different
behavior and there are three main things
in this world that drive people's
behavior in a dysfunctional way the
first one is the short termism versus
long term so we have to move the market
to the longer term Larry Fink who runs
Blackrock one of the biggest
institutions has written about that
because everybody sees this
destructiveness of that the second thing
is with this balance between men and
nature we have put the boundaries wrong
if you again again not that I want to be
religious here but if you go to the book
of Genesis it says men's dominance over
nature and we have started to interpret
that as that we can literally dominate
nature and destroy nature that we are
smarter but our intelligence was meant
to be to be stewards of nature so we
have to give nature of value in all we
do and we need to move the narrow
definition of GDP or the profit and loss
statement in the company to more
integrated reporting including the
environmental and social capital next to
the financial capital capitalists are
very good at optimizing capital but
we've only put them on a path to
optimize financial capital but if we put
a price on carbon for example we would
move much faster in bringing climate
change though just like you put a price
on water we bring water use it's done so
move to environmental and and social
accounting next to financial is
absolutely a must and then the third
element of the boundaries is really our
financial system our financial systems
rewards are all on capital and
unfortunately not on labor because they
were designed at a different time but we
have been slow in evolving it one of the
reasons that we've been slow of evolving
it is that most of the institutions that
we have created
at the time of Bretton Woods which was a
long time ago for you in the 40s but it
was when 90% or 85% of the world economy
was in Europe and the US now we have a
global economy and we haven't figured
out yet how to and it's very
interdependent and we haven't figured
out yet how to create the institutions
to rule it and we need to move to a
system where we don't reward capital you
take this country I was in New York on
Monday or Tuesday a few heads guns heads
from guys and I'm not against them but a
few heads front guys last year together
made 10 billion that tax rate probably
is 10% then they give 25 million to
charity to help the homeless in New York
there are heroes there all of a sudden
you know philanthropist of the highest
order they probably use the 25 million
also to offset their tax bill on the 10
percent and but they created the problem
in the first place because our system
rewards the capital at no tax and the
people that work and labor often gets 40
50 percent tax at a time that we need to
create more jobs we need to Excel a
subsidized labor and penalize capital
because we have enough of the capital we
don't need to get higher returns now I
think it's a very radical thought for
some people in the US but it's
absolutely needed if we want to change
the global economy after that answer I
have so many questions about what you
think of tax systems supply chains
governments world thought leaders but
I'm going to take a pause right now and
allow the audience to make a question
there's going to be a microphone over
here and we have a microphone in the
back as well okay so we have a question
right here if you can just stand up say
your name and ask one question please
you talked about supply chain system
supply chains and the role of CEOs in
that can you talk about sustainable
consumption so how do we move people
away from let's say buying more caste we
are looking at penetration of electric
cars right now in the market but have
you thought about where were we
we want to dispose the batteries in the
next 3040 years so so one of the things
that people are starting to think about
obviously is to move from this linear
economy that I briefly referred to to
this circular economy right now we're
basically digging it out of the ground
producing and then dumping it again and
if we keep digging you know you end up
in Australia and there's not much left
and that's really what we are doing so
how can you be sure that someone else's
waste is someone else's input so that
nothing goes to waste
so when Unilever we for example said we
want to run all of our 500 plus
factories that we have at zero waste we
actually achieved that two years ahead
of target by thinking about it
differently our costs go down the pride
goes up quality goes up actually
customer service goes up a lot of
benefits from doing that so the circular
economy concept thinks about moving into
that direction now it's very exciting
with Millennials actually they are not
as possessive as we were they really are
growing up in a sharing economy ubers
Airbnb set the example of that but
increasingly they feel very comfortable
by paying for experiences but not paying
for physical goods so that goes into the
right direction but having said that it
needs obviously much more so in Europe
now there is a directive on circular
economy coming in many countries in the
world don't have waste recycling systems
yet and it's difficult for countries to
do or start sometimes but if you have a
country like India or Brazil or China
not having waste recycling and Joosten
we have a problem so we've put the
global consumer goods industry for
example together to because no company
can do it alone to move into some of
that you know in targeting country by
country for example to move to recycling
systems or other things and at the end
of the day we need to which is very hard
for companies to understand we need to
stimulate consumers to use less and
people might say why would you advocate
that as a company because there is a big
difference between using less material
and creating more value I can create far
more value with less material and but
you have to think about that so so we
look at all of our products for example
do compactions - light weighting on
plastics
be sure that actually the products leave
from what's in the bottle because in
many products 15-20 percent stays in the
bottle when you throw it away and as we
do all these things you actually get
higher customer satisfaction create
other relationships with consumers you
can build value of so you have to indeed
think about a growth model without using
more stuff but creating more value in
its broadest sense and those models are
actually very successful you take food
and food in the u.s. food in the u.s.
has always been driven by calories you
would go to one of these pizza places I
mean I'm victim of it myself with my
three boys I could go to Pizza Hut and
as a European I could never understand
it because I brought him two or three
coupons and I would leave with money and
five pizzas and you know so I never
understood how the system worked but
this was you know the American dream I
guess so but there was all based on
calories and it was the lower the better
the more we could get calories and that
gave a certain level of happiness I
guess now you see in the food industry
in the u.s. is rapidly moving to
nutrition but people are willing to pay
more for less actually I would go to a
restaurant where I get half a plate I
would actually pay more so that I don't
have to you know see all that stuff I
can't eat anyway or feel very bad that
it's thrown away afterwards I actually
pay more fright now and I think that's
happening in the global economy in total
so that notion of that little bit more
Purpose Driven and and more conscious
sharing is creeping it up all in these
last two minutes that we have with you
did you share some advice most of us
here are MBA students looking to go back
into for-profit organizations and will
probably not be the CEO right off the
start so you might thank you what can we
do to bring sustainable practices into
the organizations we go into yeah first
of all don't have an ambition to become
a CEO that this is stupid ambition I
always tell people not because I don't
like my job but it's just anybody can
have that title the most important thing
is that you pursue your your purpose
whatever you feel strong about
if you figure out what where you want to
make the difference this the first thing
you need to do and some might fight for
women's rights some might want to fight
for people in emerging markets someone
want to include better education but you
need to have something that you want to
have an impact in this world and that
has to align with your values if that
aligns with your values you are going to
be successful because it will drive your
passion doesn't matter you know the
money you earn is not an indicator of
success anymore you know people's
self-worth should not be measured by
people's net worth
it's very important if you want to have
a good life and then the second the
third thing is obviously a positive
attitude is equally important because
the things never go the way you want it
to go otherwise someone else would have
done it before you so the road to change
is a road that has many skeptics or
cynics rejections but if you are
strongly driven by your purpose and your
values I think and the stronger they are
the better beacon you have in a very
volatile environment to deal with these
challenges you you stay guided as
someone once said by the lights of the
stars not by the lights of the passing
ships and at the end of the day you need
to do what you really feel you can make
the biggest difference if you're in an
unfortunate position like Horace I I
don't say it on camera but I the reason
I work in this company and give my
energy to that is because I can have a
bigger impact in doing what I do know
then I can see in any other opportunity
that is offered to me and if that is a
possibility to have a bigger impact to
change the world for the better and then
that's my duty to do that until someone
else can do it better than I do and if
in the final point I just want to leave
you as is some the importance of
positive attitude is reminds me of a
story that my father always told me of
the boiling water with the carrot the
egg and the coffee bean and the egg is
actually very soft but goes into the
boiling water and becomes very hard and
stubborn you can't do anything with it
the carrot was actually strong went into
the boiling water
became very soft and mushy but the
coffee bean went into the water and
changed the color of the water around it
which state the coffee bean so my
message to all of you has just been a
coffee bean in life everyone a big round
of applause for coke